die wirtschaft steht unter schock so
lautet die diagnose der führenden
forschungsinstitute vorgetragen per
livestream konferenz corona als
konjunktur keller bei nahezu überall
werden maßnahmen ergriffen um die
ausbreitung zu verlangsamen und diese
maßnahmen beschränken die
wirtschaftliche aktivität in
beispielloser weise auch die konjunktur
in deutschland bricht als folge der
korona pandemie drastisch ein
die institute rechnen damit dass die
wirtschaftsleistung in diesem jahr um
4,2 prozent schrumpfen wird
in der spitze könnte die
arbeitslosenquote auf 5,9 prozent
steigen die zahlen der
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute zeigen
uns auch sehr deutlich dass unsere
maßnahmen gegen die wirtschaftlichen
folgen der korona pandemie anfangen zu
wirken
es wird mit einem nur mäßigen anstieg
der arbeitslosigkeit gerechnet aber mit
einem deutlichen anstieg der kurzarbeit
die gute nachricht für das kommende jahr
sagen die wirtschaftsforscher eine
erholung voraus und ein wachstum von 5,8
prozent
die wirtschaftspolitik macht ja schon
einiges um dieses szenario wahr werden
zu lassen zum beispiel die regelungen
beim kurzarbeitergeld spielen da glaube
ich eine wichtige rolle weil sie dazu
beitragen dass die einkommen
stabilisiert werden
all das sind aktuelle prognosen
maßgebend für die entwicklung sei aber
wie schnell sich die pandemie abschwächt